okay
tacks up one he's gonna get bro i'm
starting to believe as well henry
because he's gonna take conflict
stop blowing my mind one of the greatest
leaders that we have in global offensive
today is fallen that his leadership
permeates every layer of the brazilian
scene
unable to get the adjustment off jumps
on the bottom once more ben and the one
on one here
picks him out of the air jumps back on
it
does the outline he doesn't have it
nrg take it even though some people
might say that
i might not understand the game that
well anymore i think that's not the case
i have a lot of confidence on my
abilities on that regard and simple
swaps to the usp he knows a single
shot's going to get the job done
walking into the angle falling crouched
oh he's gonna get the better of him
three kills from fallen
an excellent 1v3 when liquid absolutely
need one
it's only been two months since fallen
joined team liquid and he's already
started turning things around for this
struggling na org
but not everyone saw this coming fallen
was once a cs go legend hell he's the
godfather of brazilian cs
considering upper has alugo look low
it's the defuser fall again
that is incredible that might be the
game in itself an absolutely
brilliant play from fallen but the last
couple of years
haven't been kind to him before the
neighbors get the adjustment off
jumps on a bomb once more ben and a
one-on-one here picks him out of the air
jumps back on it does he have time
between lackluster performances and his
long-time roster mibr falling apart
2020 marked the end of a brazilian
dynasty
frustrated with everything that was
going on fallen benched himself out of
protest
meanwhile team liquid another former top
team was
also self-destructing this hard fight
this long fight it might be drawing to
an end and not in favor
of the liquid side down goes the liege
and it's all on twist 20 seconds molly
on him he's burning it alive
triumphs after a string of poor
performances
liquid ended up having to say goodbye to
long time players twists and nitro
with all the different moving pieces in
the team at the time you know grimm
coming in
nitro stepping out a dram the old coach
stepping out and just the general
confusion of who's playing where and
who's doing what and how all of this
affects everyone
in the game itself um you know
overcoming some of those and figuring
out the right path to take moving
forward was was
a huge huge challenge team liquid have
to go back to the drawing board
they need practice and they need
improvement because astralis just
eliminated them from the losers bracket
of dreamhack masters winter but behind
the scenes
fallen was practicing with team liquid
as a stand-in eager for another chance
to prove himself
i have always been good friends with
stewie so once he realized i would be
out
i got a message from from moses their
coach he asked me if i could go for some
practices to see if it would fit
just to see if it would be a bit a good
mix between yourselves
sometimes you play against people but
it's a whole completely different word
when i have to play with them right so i
think they
they want to take a look and and decide
for themselves i think they actually
uh didn't try out some other players as
well and
we found it was a good fit for everyone
involved to be joining for us together
as a primary opera and a natural leader
fallen offered liquid the two things
they needed
most we really needed someone who could
come in and have a
little bit more of like a unifying
personality for the team i think we
needed someone who
was going to have respect to the other
players as well um
who could who could um kind of focus
everyone on one single goal and
and fall in with his with his
accomplishments and his pedigree as a
player
um obviously is a natural fit in that
position
okay tax up one he's gonna get bro i'm
starting to believe as well henry
because he's gonna take conflict
stop blowing my mind but on the other
hand it
had been a long time since anyone saw
fallen in peak form
i don't think it's a good move okay i
think it would be better to get an offer
uh as someone like brokey to play the
passive op roll
fit into the system and have a stewie
call with like the aggressive rifle
style
that they have been working with in the
past i think that was the better option
some thought his glory days were behind
him that he was a dinosaur
washed up and that his next move should
have been well
retirement even though some people might
say that
i might not understand the game that
well anymore i think that's not the case
i have a lot of confidence
on my abilities on that regard phone's
first test with liquid was the blast
vermeer global finals 2020 where they
clinched a respectable top four finish
simple swaps to the usp he knows a
single shot's gonna get the job done
walking into the angle falling crouched
oh he's gonna get the better of him
three kills from fallen looking for the
perfect timing off of the flash
sees them takes down electronic oh and
he hits the flick to boom
a headshot for grimm and a first map
from not
liquid in just ridiculous fashion
unfortunately by the time the group
stage for the 2021 blast premier spring
finals rolled around
it looked like the honeymoon was over
fallen who's been the one
player kind of a little slower on the
scoreboard
tonight in a game stacked with talent
he's gonna get some deagle damage but
he's swarmed and faze clan
have picked up the first map of this
series
map is there though with a nice shot and
suddenly it's a two on three as rain
will take that leash
coming up from behind it won't matter oh
stewie gets caught and
it is gonna be the map in favor of phase
equally disappointing was
fallen's individual performance ranking
near the bottom of all players at the
tournament
but stats don't always tell the full
story and
fallen's leadership and team building
skills aren't exactly quantifiable
i actually think that taking care of the
relationships beside the team
is what makes a winning team that's one
of the aspects of a winning team i try
to make sure that
doing all the normal things that happens
inside the team people can talk out and
can really
put outside the things they think should
be different they can really give
comments on other
teammates uh approach the game and
try to have a good environment where we
can work together
as a unit to get everyone better as much
as we can
he's definitely adding a lot of ideas
that we have like if
jake isn't having a lot of ideas then
fallen is immediately
within like a millisecond he's giving
some type of idea
and trying to help out the team so i
think that he's been really helpful in
that regard just team atmosphere giving
ideas
and keeping everyone in it the question
on everyone's mind was
whether or not fallen would take over
in-game leadership duties from the
struggling stewie2k
now i just want to ask you you already
said stewie will be the ideal for now
so can you tell us a little bit about
what we're doing forever he's the best
forever
that's forever is that it you're not
going to take over at some point that's
it
why are you guys considering i will go
later it's a question maybe i'm wrong
oh no so tell me about your role like
what what is it you're bringing do you
have
everything
sometimes i'll get some kills as well
coffee all right i'll take it i'll take
it i think there's still
some areas where we can we can find to
integrate him him more and bring that
that strength of his game uh into the
team so
i mean it's kind of working it out some
games um you know he feels like there's
you know some some places where he
doesn't have the space to get involved
and some games it works fine so it's
just an ongoing process of finding that
comfort zone
and finding a rhythm between him and
jake on who's kind of uh
you know who's who's kind of uh taking
over the team in different areas
but in the days leading up to iem
kadavite 2021
the secret slipped out fallen would be
taking over as team liquid's igl
we obviously after our recent
performances we're trying to implement
fallen as our main igl now
so uh with uh someone with that like
yeah also like i said the
the op and igl role has been taken up by
him
c2k is believing for a while he is doing
a super great job in terms of
understanding the game understanding
strategies people are running the most
like what's good what's not
so i used that first moment to
take a picture and realize how those
guys like to work how they like to
operate inside the game
and outside the game we felt that with
my presence
leading the team with a little bit more
positivity with a little bit more
uh paying attention to those details
outside the game
making sure everyone is comfortable if
someone is not comfortable going to this
guy making sure we can have a good and
open
conversation about it so i think those
things is where
i can help the most katowice was
fallen's ultimate opportunity for
redemption
his chance to prove to the world that he
still had it
fallen has naf as well adds another to
the list mibr disintegrating before our
very eyes there's only one man for the
job
it's jello and he can't do it 16 the
play in upper bracket liquid continue
there mibr sent down to the lowers
he's got to go now where he's out of
time and this is all over one way or
another a brilliant shot with two
kills it's the only way he can win and
there's no reason to give him the fight
that's the game another clutch from nap
this time with the clock
it's 16 to 14 liquid
move on liquid cruised through a tough
group
even beating navi one of the best teams
in the world
to make it to the semi-fine oh he seized
the first man
damage getting done and now they have
him trapped now they've got him cornered
bitter fighting for his life
and it's fallen to close it out for team
liquid and then
liquid faced off against virtus pro
vaughn's grabbed another this really
isn't hurting vp by any means if they
rip this off out of fallen's hands
they're going to continue to throw
bodies out of the ball and they're just
absolutely wrecking it give it to every
house survive fallen will
bring the orphan to the next he refuses
to surrender his arms go down quietly
but falwen couldn't do it all with their
economy in the toilet
liquid wound up playing right into vp's
hands
not been an issue for vp in the past and
it doesn't seem like it will be an issue
here
just onto a leash then and it's clean
it's tidy it's vertus pro baby they are
here in the semi-finals with a statement
in the end liquid went down swinging
taking a close 16 to 12 loss on mirage
kick it on to the first it's all on to
grim
already find the first two vp i just
need to silence him he's got plenty of
time
advancing onto james possession he's
isolated it can he really
oh sanji the heartbreaker converters pro
they're off to the grand finals while
fourth place finish might not be the
cinderella story that some fans were
hoping for
no one can deny that the future looks
bright for team liquid and fallen i was
very satisfied with their results
and i've been learning a lot from those
guys being honest i have been playing
for
more than 17 years now and when you jump
up and start playing players on
different schools yes
you're able to realize some differences
between what you think about the game
beforehand
and what they think of some situations
and i have been
able to learn so much from from a leash
from siri those guys really know a lot
about the game so i'm using all their
knowledge to update myself
and using as a boost to get even better
and be able to
them the best way i can liquid outplaced
astralis
navi and vitality to earn their top four
finish
they stood as not just the best team
from na but
one of the best teams in the world just
a few months ago liquid was struggling
and people thought
fallen was washed but his veteran
leadership brought the team back from
the brink
and proved that you can never count out
the godfather of brazilian cs
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
you